good morning Michelle how are you I am
great when did you get back from Rio
I took a red-eye Monday night landed at
five and then went to the studio to do
the show Tuesday morning so I've been
eating great Thank You Michelle thank
you thanks for joining us that's all I
wanted you to say the difference between
sideline reporting interviewing and
poolside reporting and interviewing is
there a difference in football they're
wearing a lot more clothing so they're
you know it but I would say the amount
of water coming off of each person is
probably very similar no I think that
there's an immediacy with the swimming
and these guys and gals at the Aquatic
Center are so accessible and so happy to
talk because it's kind of their one shot
every four years - and they really enjoy
themselves doing it they seem to really
embrace the whole idea of talking about
their sport and talking about their team
and what they just did and that's not to
say that NFL players don't but they are
really used to it and it's it's more of
a demand on them constantly so I think
that's a big difference and also just
the immediacy of the race just happened
these athletes are physically fried and
and they're still catching their breath
and so you I think you get really great
kind of those immediate emotional
responses that that come when you've
just come out of the pool and your
adrenaline is you know skyrocketing
what's the interview that stood out in
Rio there were a couple I mean people
keep talking to me about Maya Dorado she
was kind of an underrated athlete coming
in and here she wins these gold and she
was just excusive and effervescent and
bubbly and fun and happy
Simone Manuel who was overcome you know
at being the first african-american
female to win an individual medal and
she wins a gold but every every Michael
Phelps interview stood out just because
you know he is making history there and
I
the last one after the medley relay when
all of his teammates were saying four
more years you know and he was like not
so but the other one though was Lily
King you know who did the finger wagging
to the Russian Yulia Efimova who had
just gotten two released back into the
Olympic Games after being suspended for
four banned substances and Lily going
out on a limb as a young kid I mean
she's still in college and saying look
if he'd used to ban sup since I'm not a
fan and she never backed down from that
I think she was she was that was pretty
cool how do you and I don't know if you
get caught up in the emotion I don't
know how you don't but how how do you
sort of maintain your calmness you've
just witnessed his history in a lot of
these races here you know it there is
kind of a celebratory feel in each of
those interviews when someone's just won
a gold medal in particular or even a
silver you know and I shouldn't say even
a silver but there were so many gold I
don't know how many silvers we even saw
but yeah there's a celebratory feel it's
it's impossible to to squelch that and
just be serious so I think you just you
know I know kind of going in what all
the back story is where I want to get
with these athletes what they've told us
before you know and it really becomes
about that moment they touch the wall in
KT libecki's case you know outside of
the 200 she was a known commodity and
you knew she was going to win so you had
to get a little more creative with her
but I don't know you I don't I don't
think it was a bad thing for some of
that joy to be exchanged in those
interviews because otherwise you're
denying these athletes a moment of
celebration so it's I I guess you've
just done it long enough you you know
how to temper yourself but it was I
gotta tell you it was really fun
Michele Tafoya from NBC Sports we have a
game tonight on NBC it's the dolphins
and it's the Falcons from Orlando then
Sunday night Bengals Jaguars we just had
a poll question first hour who had a
worst month Lochte or Hope Solo
well I would say latkes is on the
upswing you know now that he's on
Dancing with the Stars and hopes is on
the downward trajectory because she's
going to appeal this thing I guess and
I'm told it's going to get pretty ugly
so you know it's pretty even but like I
said I think things are starting to turn
more positive for Lochte than they are
for hope and she's got some nasty stuff
to look forward to in this whole appeal
process what was your poll saying oh
people uh 80% lockneys had a worst month
well I you know
listen it's it's really interesting now
that Jimmy feegan has come out with his
his story and his take on things that
you know they urinated in the grass
behind the behind the gas station they
never broke down the door he did laughs
II did pull a poster off the wall I
guess but I mean you do you have to sit
back and analyze the the whole scope of
the thing and to think that that
resulted in this international sensation
is it's kind of staggering well they
were also extorted too so you know right
I mean Brazil can say hey you know we
were offended and Rio were offended I
get it but also can somebody from their
side of this story say we're sorry that
we had people who were extorting asking
for forty six thousand dollars to give
your passport back so right I mean
there's some guilty parties I find what
Brazil did worse than what Lochte did
Lochte lied and embarrassed us and you
know I dream USA Brazil didn't handle
themselves too well either when you're
finding out more of this story there I I
agree and I knew that that we were just
going to keep learning more and more
there had to be more because there was
video tape missing and all of this stuff
and and you clearly see these guys being
held at gunpoint and you know did that
officer believe he had to have the guns
Ron in order to keep things calm I don't
know
manure there was enough bad on both
sides but I do think that that that it
was a little bit overblown
sherlocky and i do think that's why now
he's getting some sympathy I'm hearing
about a couple of companies they're
small that want to have him as a
spokesperson and I think that is a
little bit out of sympathy for this guy
all right with the game tonight when it
comes to preseason when we get to that
third preseason game that's when it gets
a little more interesting a little bit
more serious but somebody who gathers
information does interviews is there
anything different tonight than there
would be for that season opener with the
Broncos in Carolina and how you go about
whatever information you're getting yeah
absolutely I mean for one thing you want
to introduce the audience to some people
who they may never heard of who are
gonna make this team that some of the
rookie guys that are having an
opportunity and no one knows about them
and they're going to get plenty of time
so you want to be able to talk to them
or talk about them we'll be able to
interview some of the Falcons in this
game Adam GaSe said no to having the
Dolphins interviewed in the game but
that's one of the nice things about
preseason and the Pro Bowl as well is
that and you get to talk to the players
after they're done for the night and so
there will be some of that but again
it's a it's going to be one-sided at
this one I think Cincinnati
Jacksonville will be different and they
will be able to talk to players on both
sides so it's it's it's more relaxed in
that in that fashion we still prepare
every bit as much as we do for any other
game believe me but your focus is a
little bit different this game doesn't
matter in terms of the standings in
terms of where these teams are going in
the regular season it matters in terms
of personnel it matters in terms of
storylines and again you get access that
you wouldn't otherwise get ever been
injured on the sidelines no I've come
close but I haven't I have a side line
producer down there once with me whose
foot got run over by the cart cam and I
didn't know what happened until later
but no I remember one time when I was
just pregnant and the guy that was kind
of helping me on the sideline knew this
and saw something coming at me that I
didn't see and he just picked me up and
moved me out of the way but fortunately
you know why did you ask this
you just totally put the kibosh on it
you jinxed me Dan
it'll be good TV Michelle it's all about
content have fun tonight and we'll talk
soon Thank You Michelle Michele Tafoya
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience